hi this is kevin van oort standing in
for reviewer Miguel conception to tell
you about Dark Souls 2 crown of the
sunken King the road to the emotional
rewards of the souls games is strewn
with sweat-stained controllers and
saintly patience and the fear that
pervades every game in the series is
just as prevalent in crown of the sunken
King the first of three content packs
for dark souls 2 the add-ons
interconnected levels echo the woven
layout of the first Dark Souls without
feeling like a full-on throwback you'll
experience the tension of cautiously
venturing into an unexplored path only
to realize that much to your relief
you've stumbled upon a new shortcut to
an old bonfire from software builds on
this positive sense of exploration with
sets of environmental puzzles some of
which alter the shape of the landscape
itself it's not only to access new areas
but also to attain items that are
seemingly beyond reach this encourages a
level of thought and experimentation
that the main game lacked crown of the
sunken King also differs from dark souls
2 stylistically whereas Dark Souls 2 had
a clearly european look it's hard to
miss in early temples Aztecs influence
yet given the series otherworldly look
over all the contrast is neither jarring
nor off-putting crown of the sunken king
is very difficult and assumes you've
made substantial progress in the main
game by placing its initial access point
in black Gulch you'll be modestly
conditioned for the trials of shol'va
dragon sanctum and Dragons rest the
three areas of the DLC if you recall the
dark and often unsettling areas that
lead to black Gulch then you won't be
surprised at the equally dreary locales
and crown of the sea
ink
here you meet the grotesque insects
known as the corrosive egg crawlers
whose bulbous silhouettes induced
goosebumps when encountered in a poorly
lit hallway it's no wonder that many
souls fans classify the series as
survival horror combat and crown of the
sunken King is at its most rewarding
when you have the presence of mind to
use your environment to your benefit yet
sometimes you die while learning how
each new opponent behaves your tactics
and difficulty against the bosses will
depend on how much dark souls 2 you've
played up to this point crowd of the
sunken king is guilty of having bosses
who occasionally behave like three skins
of other characters sin closely
resembles the ancient dragon while Queen
Alana could be mistaken for a sister of
Queen nashandra the only boss that has
any true originality is a trio of human
sized enemies when you're dealing with
three enemies each with a different
weapon skill no two battles are alike
your only hope is to make sense of the
chaos Dark Souls 2 by itself is so rich
and robust and its challenges but still
leaves psychological scars from battles
against the likes of the poison Rat King
in the smelter demon it stand out
exploratory design and abundance of
engaging enemy encounters makes crown of
the sunken King a worthwhile playthrough
but a hair short of being essentially
you